this year Milan Turin the movies crimson
peak horror scary horror I think the
haunting the innocents
alien Jaws Texas Chainsaw Massacre for
sure I mean that that actually scare you
I would say the Exorcist but the
Exorcist when I was a kid didn't do
anything for me I was like but then I
became a parent and it became incredibly
scary
so films changed with your age but those
five scared me at the time the truth in
a world and what we need to understand
is the horror is all too human you have
to fear the living more than the dead
there is one ghost experience I had in
New Zealand in my Tomoe when I go to a
city I rent the haunted room in a hotel
it was only seven people in the whole
hotel it was closed for the season and
in the middle of the night I was
watching the wire on DVD and I hear a
murder a horrible horrible murder in the
room there was a huge balcony and I knew
I knew I just knew that if I raise my
eyes to the balcony there was going to
be somebody there tapping in the window
and I said well look at stringer Bell
I'm not I look up and I didn't sleep a
single second
you